EU finance ministers meeting in Brussels
approved a political agreement reached
with the European Parliament to
harmonize EU rules on deposit guarantee
schemes protecting savings deposits of
up to 100,000 euro ministers also agreed
on the need to come to a quick agreement
with the European Parliament on the
establishment of a common mechanism for
rescuing failing banks in a drive to
avoid any repetition of taxpayer-funded
bailouts the Hellenic presidency is
committed to do all it can within its
purview to achieve an agreement based on
mutual consensus as the best way to
guarantee the resolution mechanism
effective and efficient operation and we
want every member state to be on board
the Greek presidency will now explore
new ideas to find a compromise which is
acceptable to all parties ministers also
adopted the Commission's third alert
mechanism report which is the starting
point of the e u--'s annual macro
economic imbalance procedure the council
welcomed progress made by member states
in correcting both the external and
internal imbalances but warned that
further progress is needed in relation
to the annual growth survey 2014 the
council shared the Commission's analysis
of the current economic situation and
asks member states to continue growth
friendly fiscal consolidation tackling
unemployment and modernizing public
administration to consolidate the
incipient economic recovery as foreseen
the council adopted a recommendation on
the budget discharge for 2012 and
concluded that next year's budget should
reflect member states whose fiscal
consolidation efforts and fund
investments to boost growth and jobs